[Music]
so I'm Jeremy Oki I am a senior director
of product management with Cisco I've
specifically been working very closely
you may have heard in the keynote david
koechner talking about we work with
Google for the last year on a joint
solution that we've been talking about
we're gonna talk about that in some
detail today and so I've been running
that technical program as well so let me
start with a tale of innovation we start
usually talking about dev teams and to
pizza-box teams well I couldn't find a
pizza graphic on our internal site that
was a legal and official to use so I had
to change up a little bit so let's talk
about a tale of innovation here I have
some executives there they're
brainstorming in an undisclosed location
nice views probably around a golf
afterwards they come up with a great
idea of what they want to do soon in
this cloud world after the idea is
agreed upon they all call their kids and
see if their kids can develop a forum
actually they call the talented
architects they meet discuss the plan
and they see if they can deliver on what
the executives want to do so now we have
an innovation team of devs that gets to
work - the pizza okay so how familiar is
this to many of you how many of you have
innovation teams now working internally
on cloud native micro services etc show
of hands okay
we see this a lot doesn't really change
the fact that you probably still have
all the kind of classical IT that runs
your business and makes money but you've
got this new team that's working on all
the new and exciting stuff so what have
we kind of announced with with between
Cisco and Google really a consistent
deployment environment deploy develop
and deploy anywhere secure consistent
hybrid environment innovation on your
own terms so that's the end of the
marketing let's get into what this
actually means so I am part one of
probably a multi-part act here today
since we only have 45 50 minutes in
breakout sessions we've kind of broken
this in to multiple pieces so first and
foremost later today
go to the first one today because it's
my boss tell them I did a good job
tomorrow we actually have a technical
deep dive that's mul Cisco and Google
presenting it's going to be a lot
talking about what we're going to talk
about now but
leaning more into sto and what working
with Google on there and then the
actually put the arrow by the wrong
thing that's bad on me
io 284 is the second part of this that's
a going more into the on premise
kubernetes in the production grade
kubernetes environments so that's at
10:20 on Thursday
I put the Chevron by the wrong one so
we've been talking with us for a while
how many of you heard about this since
last August when we announced it
publicly with Google anyone been
following this since August a few about
20% ok so we announced what we were
doing with Google in October we have our
multi cloud portfolio which is Cisco's
bigger story about how we work with all
the many products that cisco has to
connect clouds we launched container
platform in Cisco live Barcelona in
January stealthWatch cloud now supports
Google VPC flow logs in March in May at
coop con we announced both our app
dynamics application performance
management product supporting kubernetes
and cloud center our cloud management
product also supporting kubernetes so
all these things have been the
incremental progress we've been making
so it may seem that a long time ago
October was but we've had a lot of kind
of incremental progress that lead us to
what the total solution is that will be
you just heard on stage shipping next
month so a little detail what it is for
half of you that maybe haven't heard
about this so cisco hybrid cloud
platform for google cloud official name
you may see it called CH CP in in
acronym in some places the on premise
and google cloud that has a consistent
environment capability delivering
security hybrid cloud management service
mesh and networking connecting what
Google does well in the cloud and what
Cisco does well on premise so what does
that kind of look like from component
perspective so let's start with on
Google cloud obviously you have all the
services and things in Google cloud
starts with google kubernetes engine
doesn't replace that you also have a
number of services today Google
advertises platform services six of them
through open service broker out to the
other areas such as an on-premise
environment so moving to the left what
do we have google Apogee I want to have
RESTful API interfaces that innovation
team that's working is familiar with
rest your mainframe or some of your
legacy applications may know
actually talk restful api even if they
do perhaps there are some other nuances
we'll get into in a minute we talk with
that use case so I have those existing
services on-premise i need maybe i want
to run kubernetes on-premise my security
officer my application data gravity I
need something on premise but I still
want it to be kubernetes but I want it
to be production ready what do I want to
run it on top of Cisco sells
hyper-converged and our traditional
converged infrastructures so hyper flex
and also software-defined networking ok
so a little bit more specifically what
are we doing in the products so on
Google cloud we are going to be offering
in August the Cisco CSR 1000v virtual
router on Google cloud to connect that
consistent connectivity between
on-premise and clouds this is Cisco's
kind of heritage we obviously have lots
of other products besides so it could be
firewalls it could be physical ASR CSI
our sis our routers it could also be
that you have a Cisco device on one side
and you want to connect to Google Cloud
VPN on the other also supported the
configuration or you could be using a
connectivity partner that's using you
know low latency high throughput Google
cloud interconnect so those are all
supported scenarios I want a consistent
security experience so combination of
firewalls and defense-in-depth that
isn't enough in a cloud world you know
we can do things like intrusion
prevention but what happens when half
the traffic goes off to the cloud so
things like stealthWatch cloud we have
sensors on premise sensors on gke and
also VPC flow logs so that we have a
full visibility because we have an
extended trust model now in the security
and then coming down onto the Cisco
container platform having the option to
run sto either on Cisco container
platform or gke
but also sto as promised you saw some
demos in the keynote showing its
automatic visibility of both sides so
Cisco's been working very closely with
Google to get that multi cloud
multi-site capability integrated in dis
tio because that's important to us
especially Conti vis our container
networking technology that then sits on
top of the physical assets so a couple
use cases will get very specific now I
mentioned Apogee on-premise so Google
apogee is also sold as a software as a
service offering but maybe you wanted
on-premise for various reasons so we in
solution are supporting deploying Apogee
edge on premise and why would you need
that maybe your application already does
have restful api maybe it doesn't so
first and foremost giving a restful
interface on premise to things that
might completely live out in the cloud
your mainframe your physical database
assets but more importantly it also can
do telemetry control who should be able
to access it
reporting maybe you want to charge the
data you have on premise is valuable to
you Apogee can create a front-end so
that you can actually charge someone
every time they pull from your API so
start to monetize your data on premise
and maybe that's your service all in
itself is getting something out past
your firewall in a very controlled
restful api way and making money from it
so second use case I have an application
on premise I want to extend out into the
cloud the couple technical sessions I
mentioned they're going to follow up
we're gonna actually demo this use case
very specifically but say for example
you have an application on premise and
your customers can put in feedback on it
wouldn't it be nice to do customer
sentiment analytics do you want to own
that and operate that service perhaps
not you can go ahead and use services
like pub/sub cloud spanner bigquery big
tables etc from Google and so the
on-premise application gets
extensibility into the public cloud to
get those additional platform services
through open service broker and Service
Catalog which are built into the
on-premise Cisco container platform
lastly the most common use case we hear
from customers maybe you want dev on
public cloud Google cloud and you want
dev on you want dev on private cloud
really it's your choice customers are
choosing to run things in various ways
one team may operate very differently
than another as well one size doesn't
fit all so I want to have a 100%
upstream kubernetes environment I
mentioned the innovation team so your
innovation team also was off in a corner
running kubernetes on their laptop
writing services re-platforming your
applications and creating this new thing
that the executives asked for and
envisioned who takes the phone call
friday night at 2:00 a.m. when the
kubernetes application doesn't work how
many guys are all production ops IT ops
kind of folks and not developers raise
the hands who's who's not developers in
the room this is a lot of developers all
right so I'm talking to you IT ops guys
you know that you take the call at 2:00
a.m. when it's broken so some of you may
not even be familiar with kubernetes
it's the world that the developers are
in they're platforming they're testing
they're developing their pushing code
they're doing things like agile and CI
CD continuous integration continuous
deployment and then they come to you and
say I'd like to take this production and
you start asking the obvious questions
is it secure does it scale is it
documented who needs access to it all
the things that developers don't
necessarily care about security you know
developers usually dvorak deliver
outcomes security oftentimes isn't built
into the application I think we're
starting to see that change with with
regulations like gdpr
we're starting to have to build more
into the application but we still need
also that umbrella of security that
covers everything so really this use
case and what we're working on is you
need to be able to deploy the developers
need to be have something they can
depend on it needs to be production
ready and who do you have to support you
when it's broken in the middle in the
middle of the night so this is a lot of
open source technology so we're wrapping
this with support so really that's the
biggest thing I think that Google and
Cisco been working on mostly is cisco
has an enterprise class technical
support capability you may already have
a lot of products from cisco routers
switches firewalls other software
products and you know you can call cisco
24/7 around the round-the-clock and
you'll get someone who will help you and
prioritize it and get it fixed for you
so that's what we're bringing to this we
also obviously have a partner ecosystem
that supports this and can design and
install it
so I mentioned secure we need to start
doing things like proactive security
threat detection integrated VPN and
connectivity is one bit but also
behavioral analysis I'm going to talk
specifically now about stealthWatch
cloud so if those of you haven't seen it
this is kind of a stealthWatch cloud
user interface I come into a dashboard
this is a SAS offering from Cisco so you
have to worry about running the platform
you just deploy the sensors and consume
the intelligence analytics that the
platform provides I see that I have a
number of sensors deployed so this
happened to be from Cisco live us last
month I have different kind of workers
deployed i have a google kubernetes
environment I have sensors deployed to I
have some VMware how many do you think
that your container
applications are never gonna talk to
anything that's your old applications
your virtuals your physical I don't
think that I think for a while we're
actually me running in this composite
mode where the new applications need to
talk to the other applications that
haven't been Reap lat formed and
modernized yet so we have our existing
data center assets we need to start
getting technical and security telemetry
from and then finally Google cloud
platform has VPC flow logs support now
that that has come out and been released
and so we have the ability to see the
flow logs the data you can't see
underneath the cloud is exposed to via
flow logs and stealthWatch cloud picks
that up so what does it mean I get
visualization who's talking to who how
are they talking what kind of alerts
what kind of connectivity how many
observations are we making looking at
networks talking to what kind of traffic
are they are they exchanging how many
connections are active looking at the
heuristics and and past performance the
last 24 hours I've had this kind of
traffic patterns and you can see there's
checkboxes where maybe I events have
occurred that you want to click into so
important thing difference from a
firewall or like an intrusion prevention
system the models are taking all these
various inputs we just described there
then correlating it with entity behavior
a firewall may say this country can
never talk to me because I don't do
business in that country or I have a
pattern match and intrusion prevention
oftentimes looks at a pattern and you
tend to get a lot of false positives
sometimes as that pattern changes but
wouldn't you like to know every day I
get these kind of connections and I then
send the connection off to Google and
the response back from Google cloud is
normally one packet that's 20 kilobytes
of an answer what happens if that
behavior changed all of a sudden I have
a million packets going out to Google
cloud and the response is now 40 K or
100k the behavior change so using kind
of a heuristic pattern matching and the
behavior analysis we're looking at the
security to say something's different so
this isn't just simply firewalls and
intrusion prevention and what do you
kind of get now I actually have very
actionable alerts hey people who don't
normally access this system have tried
to do SSH into your gke clusters drill
into it it's been accessed from a
country that doesn't normally exist
maybe this was a
in your business you'll be able to
quickly go and accept this or mark this
as something that's actionable if it's
something as normal your business
patterns have changed these security ops
folks click this and say this is normal
no longer the behavior no longer
recognizes this as an anomaly so we have
lots of information the countries will
load in with the IP addresses
everything's clickable in here to drill
in what kind of endpoints what kind of
activity do we have going through the
system so this shows your behavior of
endpoints and when your peak times and
your business are so this is an example
of the inputs that are used in the model
and the behavior analysis what kind of
traffic do we see what kind of ins and
outs how many connections internal
devices versus external devices so it's
graphing all that for you and showing
what's what's occurring now how many
you're very familiar with kubernetes in
this room again about half two thirds
all right so how many you prefer the CLI
for those you aren't familiar with
kubernetes managing this via kubernetes
means you're using coop cattle coop
control and these are the kind of
commands you use to manipulate the
environment ok so let's hop into some
demos here and kind of show you kind of
what we think is a little bit different
about what we're doing so your
innovation team may be familiar you
don't want to replace their from the
node arity with those CLI commands but I
mentioned we now have two sets of
operators I have a development team this
job is delivering outcomes I have an
Operations team whose job is to deliver
a secure stable production grade
environment so with Cisco container
platform on premise I can actually do
things like deploy clusters so I have
one I have multiple clusters here let's
make sure everything's still logged in
so I have four clusters here I've
created so container platform first and
foremost is a multi cluster management
platform I can create destroy clusters
via API be a CLI be a user interface
here okay so your IT ops folks can be
the people who create destroy kubernetes
environments on premise this also can be
extended out developers could create and
destroy their own your scripting your
automation could create and destroy it
one of the hard things about kubernetes
though once it's deployed also is the
upgrades management and logging and
support of it so container platform
specifically shows you the cluster gives
you an interface I can
how many master and nodes I have working
in the environment how they're set up I
can then do something interesting
I now have kind of a multi-tenant
environment if you will I'm the IT
operator I see all the clusters I know
have a dashboard that shows me the
health the logging the kubernetes
cluster management of the entire system
I now though can provide subsets I can
provide just a kubernetes cluster to a
dev team so no longer is it the
innovation team in the back corner on a
laptop running mini cube or on an
environment that's not connected to what
can get out to the Internet into the
public cloud now I have an environment I
can expose to them so they can very
quickly download a token and I can
actually jump over into if they are very
from other kubernetes I'm gonna let me
repol in that token I saved from
container platform and login if they're
very familiar with the kubera's
environment they're still seeing
kubernetes you're now giving them
basically a tenancy in an environment
that's managed by production operations
they can now be the support organization
so if you need distributed roles you can
do that if I office is going to
completely take it over you still can
learn and see and use communities so all
the things you'd normally see in
kubernetes are being managed by Cisco
container platform ok so let's talk a
little bit about an application I think
you saw in the keynote that Google's
passionate about hipster stuff well at
Cisco or passionate about socks holy
socks what do we have we have lots of
socks here super socks color socks cross
socks etc so this is an application my
innovation team wrote and we're gonna
run into our cloud management platform
product ok so when the developers were
deploying this they may have deployed
this using gamal files text files that
describe what the deployment looks like
how the configuration should work in
Cisco we also have a visual cloud
management product so let me describe it
a couple things the Thursday sessions
gonna go into a lot more detail on both
container platform and cloud center but
what I have here is a drag-and-drop
topology capability maybe for example
your innovation team is really good at
deploying their specific application but
you have another team that maybe is the
experts in Cassandra or your know sequel
or your relational database
or your production load balancers okay
so one team may not have the whole set
of ingredients that it takes to make the
system production therefore we have on
the left all the various components and
we're capturing the organizational best
practices and automation of all the best
components think of these like widgets
you may want a blue car you may want to
red plane we might share some widgets on
the left is all the widgets in the
Middle's where we're dragging them into
the outcome the blue car or the red
plane so this is my socks application
lots of little micro-services containers
this also could mix in maybe I need to
put in a very traditional virtual
machine-based message bus or I want to
drag out an operating system because I
need a jump box or something or I need
to drag out an NFS file system so the
drag-and-drop capability environment
means that people who don't necessarily
know as much about these individual
widgets may still be able to get the
expert organizational knowledge and add
it to their outcome okay so now I have
something that's reusable and so we
talked about I want to be able to deploy
this dev wants this on public Google
Cloud prod wants this on the internal
container platform environment or vice
versa so what we have in COI and Yama
files is technically accurate but it may
not also have guardrails so this system
also gives the ability to have tag based
governance maybe devs don't know prod
should go here and Deb should go there
or stage also goes here or maybe they
don't know that data classification
needs to go over an encrypted path and
non you know pci maybe doesn't have to
go over it so those are the kind of
things the non-technical guardrails if
you will that a cloud management
platform adds into the technical
capability innovation teams delivering
okay so when I come and look at these
deployments the user can now self-serve
see the number of deployments I have a
number of things here I have an sto
deployment my Sox application that I
showed you earlier I've deployed it so
the developer can actually see or this
could be the admin who deployed it when
did they deploy it how much is it
costing them what's the health of all
the different components things like can
I add more can I scale them all of this
can be done via IP via AVS via user
interface rather via command line
or via api's so for example app dynamics
or the other APM system you use of
choice maybe monitoring this application
now looking at the help than the user
experience and would that application
have need to be written to go and find
the innovation guys know their llamo
file and know how to scale and add
additional nodes if the middleware tier
is slow or if the store itself the web
server is slow perhaps but we already
have a lot of those integrations built
into the system also when you call
Friday night at 2:00 a.m. because it's
broken this is what the Cisco Technical
Assistance Center working with Google
will actually help you fix when it's
broken okay so all the services and
visibility is exposed to everyone not
just the innovation team that happens to
be the container in kubernetes experts
and ultimately we get it all in a nice
dashboard that shows us what's it
costing us how much we're running how
often where all of the different various
clouds were using etc ok so let's talk a
little bit about how this works in
practice and some of the other problems
we have with enterprise applications ok
so over the last couple months Google
and Cisco and sa P have been working
very closely together so ASAP is
launching data hub many of you may be sa
P Hana users they've been they just had
their sa P sapphire conference so
they've been in they've been announcing
data hub and their Hana data management
platform this is a great example of an
enterprise application so Cisco and
Google are also working with these types
of enterprise providers because they're
remodeling modernizing modernizing their
platforms and software to use cloud
native and container constructs concepts
as well so SP data hub has been
completely built on top of kubernetes
now I'm not going to go to too much
detail I think s AP is here and has a
session this week as well but really
we're describing a hybrid environment
now I have a data gravity problem
oftentimes data hub is very specifically
looking at AI and m/l streams and
databases apps with big data object
stores and IOT devices those may all be
running out in Google Cloud they may
want to bring all of that back and
coordinate it with ERP data customer
data sales data etc so s AP data hub has
components that are containerized that
can run both on ggae
and on cisco container plan
from on-premise depends on where your
data is some customers may have more
data on premise that they're actually
trying to ship out other customers may
have a lot that's being generated
outside they're trying to bring in and
do the analysis on premise so a good
example of how we're working with this
ecosystem to certify and support these
enterprise applications on top of the
joint solution between Cisco and Google
alright so what it would kind of
summarize what we're doing what you'll
see in the next couple sessions one
we're integrating so some of the
complexity to tot that we're not going
to go into here but on the Thursday
session is what are we doing southbound
do you need persistent storage so cisco
has already done the integration with
the hyper flex platform to be able to
have persistent storage as well as with
third parties so if you need to save
data you actually have access to that
save data how do I connect into the
network both physical and container
networking that's built in a container
platform how do I tie into the
management we're providing a management
interface that has a holistic view of IT
ops and then still we're not changing
I've showed you kind of Cisco's for U of
C ICD where maybe the continuous
integration is Jenkins and then we're
using clouds under deploy as the
continuous deployment but because I said
I'm given the developers a consistent
kubernetes environment that they can
still access just like they were
familiar with if they have their own C
sed pipeline it's still 100% compatible
with this I think Google started talking
about a Google cloud-based build
environment would also be able to talk
to this environment so we're not forcing
customers or development teams to change
the way they operate if you have
something you like that talks to
kubernetes directly and that works the
platform just gives you production grade
instead gives you kubernetes access to
it so all the open source API software
and tools are completely exposed 100
cent upstream so it's optimized
obviously working very closely with
Google Cloud we're testing the open
service broker we're working to
contribute to sto and make sure that
that works both on-premise and in Google
Cloud and then the support model is
completely wrapped by someone you can
call Friday at 2:00 a.m. to take your
call so this can be a little complicated
we obviously have partners and Cisco
ourselves that can deliver services to
help make all this work simply this is
an example of a QuickStart service we
offer today
install all the environment stuff on
premise that's what's in blue on the
left
maybe those use cases you saw help you
work with those use cases set up the
environment the innovation team in the
corner might need help kind of bringing
what they have into your team so these
services can help kind of deliver that
capability quickly so we have lots of
demos this goes a big boost on the show
floor just kind of show you we have some
sample applications we're using in the
demo booth if you want to see something
very specifically or dive into your
specific use cases the folks there I've
been involved very heavily in the
solution so they have the ability to
kind of show you what this looks like
they have some nice 3d demos I'm kind of
showing you they'll click through so
this is kind of what it looks like very
similar but they have a nice cool 3d
kind of view to click through it how
many guys have heard of the Cisco Google
challenged it was in a blog post
yesterday it may not be talked about too
much anyone heard about it yeah a few
enthusiastic hands alright so if you
don't know what it is
Cisco and Google are working together to
create a challenge this is an event
that's gonna run for the next few months
if you go to this URL you can learn
about it I've already seen some some
students say our students eligible sure
but we'd like to see some customers and
partners and dev teams and others it's a
great way for you to start one getting
access to this in these environments for
yourself too there's some real money
some prizes I think the top three
winners I know I run container platforms
I've donated 320 node one-year
subscriptions I think there's some cash
money there's some Google Cloud credits
and some other things so the winners
will be announced I think this runs all
the way into February which is when
Cisco live Barcelona occurs so you have
months to kind of read on this get
excited sign up but that URL is where
you can go learn more about the Cisco
Google challenge all right we also have
there's our booth you can go visit and
all the places you can follow us
[Music]